robots in greek mythology may not be the  first thing that comes to mind but they  did exist when europa was given the  island of crete to rule over there was  one major issue the island was  constantly being invaded by thieves and  pirates hephaestus who was no stranger  to building automatons created the giant  bronze man known as talos he would  patrol the shores of crete three times a  day searching for any pesky invaders  talos had only one floor a vein that ran  from his neck to his ankle that was held  shut by a single nail accompanied by  jason medea convinced talos that she  could make him immortal by removing the  nail from his ankle talos believing that  he was human agreed the i-corps flowing  through his vein was the life force that  powered talos with the nail gone it  flowed out of him like molten lead and  he died